hey everyone I'm Kristen Gill and you're
watching how to Hollywood today I have
another et online host Deidre Behar here
with me as our model and I'm also here
with celebrity makeup artist Etienne
Ortega yeah so today I'm so excited to
show you guys not to get
Selena's signature inspired look with my
brand-new pure Pro palette mine honor of
Hispanic Heritage Month let's get
started anything first eileen mat so
we're gonna start off this look by
starting with the eyes and we're gonna
be using my pure palate Pro shadow
palette and before we get started one of
the best tricks for makeup is
translucent powder and a little
triangular sponge and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna apply some loose
powder under the eyes to protect any
fallout and it prevents it from ruining
or beautiful face that we've already
started so before we start I have
already prepped her eyes with a little
bit of concealer and close I'm just
gonna go back into it and make sure that
there's no creases so we have a long
lasting application so since we're doing
a Selena inspired makeup you know Selena
was all about like the 90s everything
the 90s was like matte and lots of lips
and cat eyes but ultimately very matte
eyes and I have actually designed this
palette to be very versatile so there's
tons of matte colors in here but there's
tons of sparkly shimmery beautiful
nighttime shades as well to start this
look we're gonna use this color called
stripped and it's really really sheer
and translucent and I'm just gonna kind
of go all over the lid to have like a
good foundation for the rest of our
application now that we prepped I with
the color strip we're gonna go into the
crease with the color called from 1988
and it's a very matte Brown and I'm just
gonna start focusing it on the outer
corners of the eye into the crease and
I'm using a very fluffy blending brush
how do you think Selina inspired makeup
over the years I think Selina inspired I
saw really like Americans Mexicans I
think she put her mark on the on this
world and like I'm proud to be Mexican
you know because of her like what she
did with her career and you know so
short but it's cool that she's still
like super relevant and people still
love her and her music you know my
friends are always watching like eat the
videos of her like performances because
we just love the way you know she moved
on stage and her wardrobe and her makeup
everything so like it was that moment
but I actually loved her slow songs I
don't know why like no my kid of us
yes that was my that might be my
favorite
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we should create a pallet with all
selena songs buddy so cool uh where do I
sign up
oh I would have loved to done her makeup
I was just gonna say what is she like
probably number one on your list of
people that you wish you could have done
I think her in Marilyn Monroe I mean I
would have loved yes yeah totally
different but iconic no what would you
have done I mean I think if Selena was
still around I feel like she'd be into
the makeup and she'd be into the whole
glamour and you know so I feel like we'd
have so much fun together if you had a
favorite outfit or look all the bustier
they're so legendary I used to love when
she wore the little hats like where
there was no hair and she was just like
a hat
yeah and I like a little bra with like
high-waisted pants like I love how she
looked like this so with the same color
1988 I'm gonna go in with a tighter
brush so Selena's eye looks were always
very mad and very like warm and easy you
know I think her thing was more like the
lips
so these tones are like really really
perfect too soft and and matte to try to
recreate any Selena look now that we've
done that we're gonna move on to a color
called muddy with a really tight
blending brush I'm just focusing this
color on close really close to your lash
line so I think Selena always had like a
nice crease like a really light lid with
like a super soft matte crease so I'm
gonna be applying this color called
dreamer this is really light just like
dreaming of you
[Music]
exactly and I'm just gonna apply this on
the inner corners of your lid to open up
the eye a little bit more this palette
honestly is like when I was designing it
I really thought about how to make
something that would be really timeless
how long was that palette in the works
for for like a year
it's a time yeah because then once you
put colors and you have to you know go
through the formulas and see what you
like what you don't like and then after
that comes the creative process which is
like designing the logo and the
packaging it's it's so much fun like I
would do it any day now you're gonna get
to see how easy it is to just fade out
all this powder right under the eye so
I'm just gonna get a fluffy little brush
and just sweep it all out there's no
shadow left behind everything's clean
and we're gonna be curling your lashes
because if you want a really nice open
eye this is a trick to do it I'm gonna
be using Revlon mega multiplying mascara
and we love this mascara yes if you want
to thick thick luscious long lashes I
love this mascara and it's you know
super affordable I always like to do two
coats for more intensity
I think Selena was really about lashes
you know she always she always had a
very simple cute eye and then I think
the lash and the lip were we're
definitely her thing so now I'm gonna
contour you cheeks just a little bit to
refine them I'm gonna keep it simple cuz
I think in the 90s it was more like I
said it was about the eyes the lips so
I'm just gonna refine your features a
little with what some bronzer and I love
this shade by NARS called Laguna suck in
your cheeks and I'm just gonna place a
color right where a hollow is
before I had I'm not gonna do blush cuz
I love the contoured look that we have
going on on the cheek so I'm just gonna
do some highlight and this is by dose of
colors and the color Mellon aid and I'm
just gonna write eyes point of your
cheeks to finish this look we're gonna
do Selena's legendary lip which was a
big red overdrawn I mean she had very
big lips but if you want to get that
look you know we have to overdraw it and
I'm gonna be using Mac's break it's one
of my favorite Reds and we're gonna
start by lining your lips in the center
why do that - to balance the lip to
really get an idea of you know where to
draw your your heart shape or whatever
look here chakri would you say your
favorite memory of selena is watching
her live performances I always go back
and watch her last concert I think that
was her the houston astrodome yeah with
the purple yeah I was like such a
legendary moment for and having people
dressed up for Halloween people conquer
both yep yeah yeah the energy in that
you could tell him that the day of that
show it was like crazy energy and you
could feel it through like our little
youtube screens so just to bring up the
lip just a little bit I'm gonna be using
this Charlotte Tilbury gloss and red
vixen just to add a little bit of more
drama and I'm just gonna place it in the
so there you go and now we've got a our
Selena on or is it close we got to go
transform
[Music]
thank you so much for being here thank
you guys for having a yes and recreating
this Oh fun fabulous look oh my god if
you guys want to see more videos like
this please like and subscribe to
entertainment tonight's YouTube channel
and don't forget to follow Etienne on
social media that's where you see all of
his players yes bye guys thank you
[Music]